you
[Music]
produces so let's start by making sure
we understand why we're writing code in
the first place what we're trying to do
is data science through code we're
trying to answer questions and make
predictions that are difficult to do
manually so we automated in the code
ideally we do so in a way that is
reproducible and easily augmented and
that facilitates collaboration and
outcome distribution and if we come up
with some code that we think that would
be useful to others we can show that to
if we do if we write a package for it so
code is written in the service of
analysis it's a means to an end but it's
also an artifact this is really
important your code is not temporary at
least not if you ever want to run it
again so we should not be treating it as
an afterthought it should be a primary
concern because you are going to need to
run it again someday and you need to
trust that it will produce accurate
results every single time you do run it
so since the code behind our analysis or
prediction is important we should know
what we want out of it ideally we want
reliability the ability to depend on our
code producing the correct results and
we want confidence that our functions
won't break when new data comes in or
that one area of the code won't break if
you make a change to one area of the
code it won't break another area of the
code we also want reproducibility so
that you and others can run the same
code with the same data and get the same
results every single time flexibility
goes hand in hand with extensibility in
many cases we want to be able to handle
different datasets inputs contexts
things like that and we need to be able
to extend what we've already written to
make in current incremental improvements
to the code and in our projects we want
our projects to have longevity to be
relevant for the long term and to
accomplish this it has to be
straightforward to update we want to
make it easy to iterate on the code
since small changes over time are easier
to absorb than a huge code drop in much
the same way it's easier to put 20
dollars away a week for a college fund
rather than to find a thousand dollars
at the end of the year to drop all at
once finally we need the code to be
available flexible enough to handle more
users additional variables or inputs and
potentially larger data sets as well so
the overarching need here is to be able
to trust the outcome of our analysis
which is directly related to the quality
of a code that is produced that is
producing their results code quality
doesn't matter we should be examining it
to make sure that it's up to snuff
how do we do that well we can get some
feedback during script execution in the
form of console output logs errors
warnings and things like that when the
code runs locally and we also get user
feedback from the people who are running
the script are launching the shiney
application we could wait till it breaks
in the field but it's better to check it
yourself before you release it to the
rest of the world the best way to do
this is to create tests to verify the
quality of the code test check the
output of the script to make sure it's
doing what it should check and test
themselves unit tests especially are
separate are files that are designed to
exercise the functional code to see how
it handles various inputs and
integration points and by that I mean
pieces of code that rely on the output
of other pieces of code like a function
that relies on the output of another
function so you want to examine how
quickly it runs as well and how well it
lives under how well it runs under load
to gauge this performance one of the
biggest benefits of testing is that
you're able to make faster updates to
your projects because you run your tests
up if you run your tests after you make
the changes you'll get quick feedback on
the impact of those changes so the act
of writing the tests increases your
visibility into internal dependencies
which were those integration points that
I just mentioned and you'll potentially
gain a greater understanding of the
meaning and the intent of the code
because you really need to understand
the code extremely well in order to be
able to test it effectively ideally when
you write these tests you're going to
want to cover all of your code paths but
practically speaking you're going to
want to start with the major functions
inputs and integration points you're not
going to be able to test everything all
at once so focus on the parts that you
think may be the most fragile once these
tests are in place you can then expand
to other areas of the code once you've
gotten sort of those major areas covered
first manual testing so you're gonna do
this as you're developing your code
you're going to run things in the
console just to make sure things are
working they're spot checks you want to
make sure that the the stuff that you're
writing is actually producing the
results you expect the problem with
those though I mean they're very good
you want do you want to run them and
make sure stuck things are working but
the problem is you're not going to
remember what you ran three months later
when you go to change the code so it's
really easy to have things break areas
that used to work might break because
you don't remember what tests you ran
the first time to make sure that it was
working in the first place so to avoid
this problem you should convert some of
those manual tests into a set of coded
tests coded tests are called unit tests
in this context because they exercise
small units or pieces of a larger whole
and you'll want to run these often again
because you're gonna get feedback right
away when you make changes if you find
an issue several weeks later in after
you've moved on to other things
tracking down the cause of that problem
is really difficult it's much better to
build these in from the beginning if you
can rather than to wrestle with a
fallout later so writing tests now
rather than waiting for bugs to appear
later is the classic case of an ounce of
prevention being better than a pound of
cure so now that I've convinced you that
writing unit tests is a good idea let me
show you how easy it is to get started
one of those is popular and useful
packages for our code testing is test
that it's part of the tidy verse and it
provides functions that make it easy to
describe what you expect a function to
do including catching errors warnings
and messages you can use the functions
and test that to exercise any project
but here I'm going to give an example of
test that on a package to get it set up
it's three easy steps you install the
package test that you'll also want to
install use this because we're going to
use that package it's a workflow
management package that makes it easy to
get going with projects and in this case
it has a really nice function called use
test that that sets up the
infrastructure for your tests and then
to write the tests themselves also and
use this use you
test function and that will create and
open up your very first test file so
let's see how that looks
can you see that okay I'll try that
so here's a small demo package with
three files that I have in here see I
can make this a little bigger it's small
there's only three three files in here
just a couple of functions in here there
dummy functions just for the purposes of
this demonstration but I'm going to show
you how easy it is to get the attesting
infrastructure set up here so here's my
package over here looks pretty similar
to what you'd use before you've seen
before so I've already loaded my
libraries I've already installed use
this and test that so I'm gonna run use
test that function here and you'll see
here that it created a brand new test
directory down here within that is the
test that directory and this is where
most of your tests are gonna live to
create the very first one I'm going to
do the use test and I'm actually not
going to do add it actually doesn't
matter what I pick I'm gonna pick the
add things a set of functions and what
it's done there if I go back into the
test that is already created this our
file for me and open it up for me with
some dummy tests again this is very
simple you're gonna want to change this
obviously nobody cares but two times two
you don't really need to prove that but
that's just how easy it is to get going
so I'll give you an example here this is
from the string our package and this is
taken straight out of Hadleys book but
this will give you an idea of what your
tests are gonna look like at the top you
have a context which is a description of
the tests that you're running here and
then you have each of these little
sections here the test that is the test
itself it's exercising the output of a
single function with one or more
expectations and the expectations
themselves describe the expected result
of a computation you can have multiple
of them here you see they're all using
expect equal but if you look at the
documentation for test that you have a
lot of different choices you can test
for a known error you can test for
matching you can test for all kinds of
things using these functions
so I'm gonna go back over into the code
and here this is basically that same
dummy package that I've been working
with but I've already created tests here
so you'll see in my art package I've got
three different related sets of cough
unction and then I have tests for each
of those in the test that subdirectory
here what I'm gonna be looking at here
is the unique if I things function or
the unique of five function rather which
takes a character vector and spits out
the unique values it's not very
interesting but it's pretty good for a
demo and then there's some related tests
that I've already written over here so
to run these if you're in our studio you
can do command or control shift T it'll
run all the tests in a package and
you'll see the output over here in the
build can you read that okay let me see
if I can make that bigger over here in
the build it'll give you the output of
that and you'll see that it's just
running dev tools tests under the hood
and over here in the output you'll see
the different context that it ran those
are the contexts that you have the top
of your test file and then you'll get
some feedback on whether they passed or
failed and these all passed that's great
so at this point I'm gonna make a change
to my code I right now I'm only
expecting a character vector but I want
to be able to handle factors as well so
I'm gonna add some very simple code to
be able to handle factor factors this is
great I'm gonna save it I'm gonna run
the test because I just do this as I
have it just make sure everything's
still working and it did not like that
what I do oh did I I was really smart to
me wasn't it all right thank you
let's try that again thank you and in
this case you're gonna see that one of
my tests failed so over here you still
have the context over here in the in the
output but you'll see that one of them
have failed and it tells me why it says
unique if I does not handle factors
that's the benefit of having a really
descriptive name here in your test I can
now go looking for that and says oh well
I had a test because it didn't use to
handle factors I was proving that it
didn't use to handle factors in this
case it does now so I need to change up
my test now I am going to expect it to
handle factors I'm gonna run the tests
again life is good they're all passing
now so once you have this set up this is
a really simple development workflow you
modify your coasters your co2 your tests
you test the packages with command shift
T or develop our dev tools test and you
repeat until all the test passes so as
you're designing these tests you're
gonna want to take put yourself into the
shoes of the user the consumer of each
function what would you expect to happen
what are some common mistakes or typos
that you might anticipate that a user
will will put in there for you you're
going to want to focus on your external
interfaces your code your input types
and integration points since those are
the areas that tend to be most fragile
right one test from each behavior so
that you always know where to find the
tests for a given behavior and when you
discovered up bugs right test for those
as well so you're notified if they get
if they crop up again later as you're
writing these tests you may find that
parts of the functional code would be a
little easier to test if they were more
isolated we'll come back to that later
in the talk but generally speaking if
some area of the code is hard to test
it's also going to be hard to maintain
but before we get to that let's take a
look at some shiny applications
Joe talked about this a little bit this
morning and Winston did a really nice
talk on this last year so I'm not going
to get too deeply into this but I wanted
to give you a quick idea of how this
works this is also really easy to set up
it's also three steps just like test
that but shiny test works a little bit
differently
compares the state of the application to
a previously expected the state of the
application the shiny ups because
they're in our interactive are a little
more difficult to test straightforwardly
so this is a I can't remember t called
it but you're comparing the state of the
application for the way you expect it to
the state of application where is
working right now it's kind of a
snapshot based testing strategy so easy
to setup there's basically three
different things to do you want to
install your libraries you want to
record your test or take that initial
snapshot and then later on you run the
test stop function to test it and then
compare it against your previous
snapshot first you start by running
record test this will open up an
interface where you have your target app
on the left and a recorder app on the
right and what you would do is over in
your target app of the number one in
this light here you make changes to your
application you do controls you you act
as if you were a user and then over in
number two over here in your recorder
app you'll notice that it's recording
everything you do at some point you take
a snapshot which is number three up here
then you give it a name and save it
which is number four there so you're
basically recording what a user would do
in setting up that state then when you
hit once you record it and save it
you're gonna it's going to open up the
file for you you can edit it if you want
to you can change it up in this case
we're not going to do that we're going
to move on and we're going to run test
app now and you're going to run that
same app and run it it's going to play
back those things that you recorded
earlier if everything if everything's
the same it'll just say pass but if it's
different you can it gives you the
option to take a look at why so when you
hit Y you can take a look at the JSON
encapsulation of that state which is
number one here you can also look at
some screenshots number two here again
I'm not getting into this because it's
online and Joe talked about it a little
bit this morning but you can you can
toggle back and forth and see what the
differences are if you're okay with the
differences or you're you've made it
some changes and the updated version is
what you want number three here you can
update and quit or you can just pick
and then investigate why it might have
gone wrong if it's not what you expected
so getting back to something I alluded
to earlier designing for your ease of
testing is also designing for ease of
maintenance and so there's some good
software practices involved here so
let's talk about that quickly again your
goals are reliability reproducibility
flexibility longevity and scalability
you want a good user experience and you
want a high degree of confidence that
everything you're doing and all of your
changes aren't going to break what
you've already done well before you also
want to take a look at a modular design
for ease of testing and maintenance
break things down it's much easier to
test a small function than it is to test
a huge function because you it's much
more easy to control the inputs and
outputs that way you want to decouple
your your code pullout helper functions
things like that to make it easier to
maintain later don't repeat yourself
keep it simple if you can so I don't
mean keep your analyses simple I mean
keep the pieces of your analysis your
pieces of code as simple as possible
again so they're isolated and easy to
test and maintain and you want a
consistent coding style so that it makes
it easier for future you to read or for
your colleagues for that matter then on
the shiny test side of things for
example you want your your ease-of-use
user experience tested the state of that
application when you've done a certain
set of user actions you want that to be
as consistent as possible and you can
and you can prove that with some shiny
tests and finally you want to make sure
that your error handling is good you
want to make sure if something does go
wrong that the message you give your
user is actionable so at that point yeah
profit however you have to remember that
the actual tests themselves are not
going to insure the high quality of your
script your application they just verify
it when it's there you need to develop a
workflow of adding these tests as you go
along to ensure that you're actually
building in the good code in the first
place so I'm gonna close up here with
some resources there's some really good
things you can read or watch there is
the art packages and advanced hour books
by Headley Wickham are an excellent
place to start
not only for testing but also for good
software design in general and I will I
wanted to add to that as well it is
never too late to start if you've got a
big package and you you're like
intimidated by it I've certainly
inherited packages that I'm in somebody
by just our small stress small add
something in follow headlights advice
it's a really good advice it's not hard
to get started it's three steps there's
also this Charles grey blog post on test
that auto test I'm not gonna eat and I
don't have time to talk about it but you
can basically turn on auto test and
every time you save your file it'll run
your test for you it's immediate
feedback and it's a really cool way to
do stuff if you if you have enough
tested to make it worth your while
and finally again I'm going to refer to
Winston shanks talk on shiny Tesla they
did last year it's an excellent video if
you have a chance to watch that
resources for testing packages these are
all I didn't talk about most of these I
just didn't have time but all of these
pink links are these pink words are
actually links so if you want to pull
down my slides at the end of the
conference you can go through these are
really excellently documented and so you
can read all about them there as well
next steps
start small give it a go there's no
reason not to do this it's three steps
you don't have to do everything in the
world right at the very beginning you
can start with your major functions and
move on from there look for
opportunities to improve the functional
code to be more testable and therefore
maintainable and your future self will
thank you I did trust me I've been there
so if you are running yeah if you are
using source control checking your tests
as long as your as well as your
functional code so that it always stays
in sync with what you're actually
building and if you have a continuous
integration system like Jenkins or
Travis it will if you check it in with
your code there's there pretty easy ways
to plug it in and have it run those
tests every single have run the tests
for you as part of your rate of build
integration system for your packages and
then you can bask in the warm glow of
reliability and maintainability because
your chests are telling you whether or
not you've broken something and you
don't have to guess and you don't have
to wait for your users to find it thank
you very much if you want to have any
questions about this or anything else
feel free to email me I'll be around in
the Pro lunge as well later and slides
and co2 samples will be available after
the conference thank you
you
[Music]